[Musica]
[Applauso]
honda e norton resi bild bettolina non
alessia
de beeck bis l'anno d'ora vasca per
l'inter lo show la del a combustibile
bruxelles
sede la love has been anno temibile
rivale urta cota sera clear that just a
titus arriva su trading
hans brano visco
rastatt
todi la panna di stizza che in ambio la
trinité male uomo da ca conestabile vela
canellesi ce n'è di sangue le flash card
ai e stanley sistema semi sadako vena ma
in school
allora una sera club omaggio a la seu z
note skies nel tour del sì gen
la poppata nano sport on su cui si ode
glik e cha hanno una scelta
nasce la nascita nascita hanno sera del
bot tesco curi calo del pil tedesco
couric al nassau stabile hanno altri
pari al awda 3d lato grave dato bola
kata che date numerabile del piccolo
eto'o deco da stabilirsi da
allora una spessa oserà hanno una
special manager swiss nola da una ma sta
attenta ed energia cchi nasce la nasa la
nascita a notes pesco curi calo
allora nave dalla dall'approdo in vetta
lontana nibile assad hanno una ruck la
ghiaia vindictus a nuti sembrerebbe
nasce la rude e bluetooth che il piccolo
non a gavi dalla wada legge a noah puck
tool imperia vietnam luigi in hawaii usa
strong con il letto brison della la
dinamica che turisti ad una mano allo
schema una guida né un
sack
napoletano non è un gap a led nola a non
amura club
wide da casa di cody l'asta un
carteggio sciocca ma non ho poi di due
l'hanno seguita per blair hanno pravo
veda cosa ne novità di sotto del
dio ti batterà sta molto vicino
ansamed jat muta ho sporto
manutenzione dell us navy da sempre
ferma le contrattazioni
formale contro milizia età 11 danno
beaumont wave y così
tenero sayan ska pravets questa era una
favola resiana tratto da una favola
resiana e ho pensato di iniziare il mio
intervento così nella mia lingua per
farvi sentire un po un pezzo molto
grande e una fetta molto grande e della
nostra identità dell'identità di resia
ne
sono molto orgoglioso di portare su
questo palco il tema dell'identità che
un tema alla fine molto complesso quindi
ho cercato di
confezionarlo un po
secondo la mia esperienza sono di resi
appunto mettiamo questi nabuccolo ma il
soprannome di famiglia e piazzava della
famiglia plot quindi abbiamo dei del
soprannome di famiglia
la lingua è un elemento fondante
dell'identità di una comunità e la
nostra lingua una lingua ricca molto
complessa perché prima faccio un inciso
ho parlato sino resiano ma il
sangiorgino quindi babies che la
variante di san giorgio perché dovete
sapere che
la nostra complessità si riversa anche
nella nella varia nelle varianti
linguistiche perché abbiamo la variante
di san giorgio con cui mi sono espressa
prima c'è la variante di pratto di
stolvizza odiose acqua di viva e di uche
ha quindi veramente una comunità
parlante numericamente non
esorbitante ma molto molto varia
una lingua misteriosa la nostra al
centro dell'attenzione di molti studiosi
che hanno inteso indagare su quelle che
sono le origini
anche tanto mistero attorno anno e
quindi si ipotizza perché si favoleggia
proprio no ci sono anche dei miti che ci
riguardano che riconducono la nostra
comunità di antiche origini anche
lontane come quelle russe anche favorite
che ne so anche da semplici canzoni come
la conoscete tutti probabilmente la rose
ha né dalla russia l'antenato
stabilizzati a dean sono tutti i miti
che si ci fanno piacere perché comunque
siamo orgogliosi quando siamo centro
dell'attenzione ci piace a raccontarci
ma alla fine non sono un esigenza che
noi abbiamo forse un esigenza altrui
quella di definirci perché noi in realtà
siamo resi anni e solo resia né ci
sentiamo proprio così e anche gli
studiosi che sono arrivati in valle
hanno sempre diciamo a me sotto nei loro
appunti proprio questo inciso che ci
sentiamo un po veramente diversi e unici
rispetto proprio l'innovazione con
termini con cui abbiamo condiviso la
storia politica amministrativa quindi
anche friulani agli italiani in generale
ma come si forma l'identità bell
identità si forma dei primi anni di vita
e quindi tutto quello che noi
apprendiamo nei primi anni di vita è un
bagaglio che noi ci portiamo per la vita
no
un'identità che ci condizionerà per
sempre tra le braccia della mamma quindi
tra le braccia
debole della mamma che noi abbiamo
quello che si dice l'imprinting no e
acquisiamo anche in un codice
linguistico che appunto si chiama lingua
madre non a caso si chiama lingua madre
ma la lingua non è solo un modo di
parlare come potete ben sapete anche voi
la lingua al di là di un codice
linguistico
e come un grande contenitore
che quasi un mondo perché è un modo di
pensare un modo di vivere attiva certe
aree cerebrali piuttosto che altre no
ogni lingua quindi ogni popolo che
parlano la lingua diversa ha un modo di
rapportarsi alla vita è così anche per
esami quindi non è scontata la lingua
per l'identità è molto importante e un
po l'identità e come
possiamo anche a con diciamo così come
similitudine a costare l'identità alle
fase di maturità di una persona perché
noi quando nasciamo appunto riceviamo
questi primi insegnamenti no e quindi
cominciamo a formare un'identità poi
quando cresciamo che ci dobbiamo
confrontare con gli altri
così come un fanciullo che in
adolescenza diciamo si scontra con e si
relaziona con l'esterno entra un po in
crisi ecco che comunità come la nostra
che sono diciamo numericamente inferiore
rispetto al mondo in cui sono inseriti
in cui vivono
magari si entra un po in conflitto ha
una certa fase della propria vita perché
ti rendi conto che sei molto diversi
dalle persone con cui ti rapporti per
motivi poi di studio di lavoro e sociali
insomma no e quindi ti senti si diverso
ma viene visto in maniera diversa a
volte viene visto in maniera diversa
anche in senso negativo con diffidenza e
quindi un po vacilla questa tua identità
poi però come l'adolescente che cresce
ecco che anche la maturità cresce arriva
il momento in cui un amatori l'identità
matura con te e fa parte del tuo modo di
esprimerti e non ne farei mai più o meno
anzi sarei orgoglioso di portarla con te
e ti fanno vedere agli altri come sto
facendo io in questo momento
però l'identità non è solo lingua perché
è fatto di tanti altri aspetti
noi abbiamo un patrimonio materiale e
immateriale molto vasto la musica al
ballo tradizioni le prove di favore
siano come abbiamo sentito prima
e diciamo che la vita ci ha portato a
essere anche molto duri nel rapporto con
gli altri perché comunque ci ha temprato
la fatica e lavorare duramente
una terra comunque la nostra la val
resia ricca di tantissimo ma povero di
tante altre cose
però siamo anche un popolo che ha dentro
una gioia e una voglia di vivere di
ridere di scherzare immensa infatti un
altro elemento della nostra identità
molto forte e la musica e il valore
siano che proprio vanno a braccetto ecco
l'immagine dalle mie spalle esprime
molto bene anche quello che è proprio il
carattere dei resi anni e no questa è la
posta vanno adria la domenica di
carnevale
ecco se noi siamo qui se io su questo
palco sento suonare la musica resiana
non posso stare ferma mi dove
necessariamente muovere perché questo mi
smuove dentro qualcosa e così è per
tutti noi resiano quindi dicevo duri
serie lavoratori molto concentrati nel
lavoro se conoscete qualche resiano
potete darmi del conferma siamo molto
concentrati molto seria e molto dure
però sappiamo anche scherzare sappiamo
anche godere delle bellezze della vita
siamo anche molto ironici di fatti tanti
modi di dire
desiani sono proprio improntati allo
scherzo le identità sono molto diverse
l'una dall'altra ci sono diverse
identità
quindi devo necessariamente farne
accenno vi sotto il tema e questo ci
sono identità nazionali ad esempio noi
resi anni nazionalmente siamo italiani
perché abbiamo sempre condiviso le sorti
della repubblica
ci sono le identità regionali e ci
sentiamo friulani siamo soli venezia
giulia e noi sì ci sentiamo friulani ci
sono le identità politiche linguistiche
che abbiamo già visto culturali ci sono
identità di tipo personale di tipo
sociale
tutte queste identità
hanno in comune un fattore il senso di
appartenenza e di identificazione ad un
gruppo o un luogo in particolare che
quel senso di appartenenza di
identificazione che per noi è una forza
per tutti quanti noi e sviluppa dei
legami emotivi molto importanti perché
ci rende forti e consapevoli di
appartenere a qualcosa di unico
tutte le comunità
hanno dei simboli
questo alle mie spalle e uno dei nostri
simboli il monte canin con il suo
2587 metri quando noi ci raggiungete
raggiungete la barresi a non dalla parte
della tav al torre che è uno degli
sbocchi e delle vie di accesso quindi
acea sala carnizza e quindi giù in
varese nella vallata principale ma
quando arrivate da rifiuta
è come se vinco né asti qualcosa un po
di angusto no perché vi sembra quasi di
andare in un avallato dio dove sto
andando
però poi dovete pensare che noi resi
anni
siamo molto emotivi no con i nostri
simboli come in questo caso e quando
facciamo con la famosa curva e
soprattutto rientriamo in vale dopo
diverso tempo facciamo con la curva e
vediamo questa cosa questa catena alle
nostre spalle ci emozioniamo tantissimo
perché è il nostro simbolo lui el il
monte canin che ci veglia ci protegge e
ci venga veramente veglia sulla nostra
storia la nostra storia ultramillenaria
perché siamo in questa bellissima
regione da più di 1400 anni quasi 1500
e quindi lui è lì che ci accoglie ci
saluta ci dà il buongiorno c dalla
rivederci
e quindi noi siamo emotivamente molto
legati a questa montagna siamo un popolo
migratore perché siamo qui vi ho detto
prima da un certo periodo di tempo anche
se è un lungo tempo siamo arrivati qui
al seguito della discesa di queste tribù
slave non
è
queste montagne per un certo qual modo
che ho detto prima che ci proteggono
ci isolano ma fino ad un certo punto
perché in realtà la comunità di resa e
resi anni per ragioni di sostentamento
sono dovuti emigrare anche dopo in
diversi periodi no ci siamo siamo abili
commercianti mercanti conoscete tutti
gli arrotini resiano e quindi
l'artigiano e quando irrisione
rientravano in vale ovviamente
importavano fra virgolette con le novità
del tempo per cui le innovazioni se
dovessimo chiamare con il termine di
oggi e anche prestiti linguistici quindi
si
resiano una lingua
slava arcaica ma anche molti prestiti
tra cui anche prestiti friulani perché
abbiamo sempre condiviso comunque la
storia politica amministrativa
dei dei friulani alla fine
come ci vediamo e come vediamo gli altri
mi sentirò ryan scritto i drughi scott
brooks of the last beat nick the bush
che ovvero noi siamo resi a nichi non è
di lesa per noi molto semplicemente tu
dell'asc è un italiano
così in senso generale oppure dennis chi
vuol dire tedesco di bush uno sloveno
per cui ancora questo forte identità che
ci fa un po sentire al centro
dell'universo
ma non proprio in quanto
così soli nell'universo ma un colore
dell'armonia generale dei colori
questo è l'asse di disfunzione genetica
delle popolazioni proprie europee giusto
una cena questo progetto che ancora di
più ha dimostrato un po quella che è un
po l'unicità anche genetica dei resi
anni noi siamo quelli laggiù in fondo
ospiti di gente unica questa è una
verità simpatica giusto per dire resia
né unici al mondo certo che no
auspici mi piacerebbe che ristabilisse
mo il valore dell'identità nella sua
forza proprio nella sua valenza positiva
questo concetto è stato in effetti voto
bistrattato nel tempo no per cui noi
pensiamo le identità come qualcosa di
oscuro di brutto di anti europeo anti
globali no niente di tutto questo
dobbiamo riscoprire il valore
dell'identità
come un modello di
così per portare avanti questi sani
valori perché nella diversità noi siamo
comunque
facenti parte di una comunità
quindi l'identità resiana musa
ispiratrice del futuro
qualcosa però sta cambiando
l'unione europea pensate solo nel 2012
leggo ha ricevuto il premio nobel per la
pace per aver contribuito a trasformare
la maggior parte dell'europa da un
continente di guerra in un continente di
pace eppure sappiamo benissimo tutti
quello che sta succedendo
ecco tralasciando insomma la
depredazione di natura geopolitica che
non mi competono è un po rischio le
identità l'identità di tutti no e questo
diciamo è un pericolo
vorrei concludere dicendo che l'identità
come senso di identificazione al doura
comunità assume un valore molto
contemporaneo in questo ci rende
individui
cittadini del mondo con solide radici
fatta di buoni propositi
ecco che resia di eresia diventano una
musa ispiratrice per il futuro in quanto
culla di una cultura
conservatrice si ma non oppositrice che
nel tempo ha saputo rafforzare il senso
di identificazione con valori improntati
alla pace alla pacifica convivenza tra i
popoli
in effetti resia ne sono emigrati molte
parti del mondo ma se sono sempre
adattate al nuovo ambiente anche
accogliendo nelle regole giustamente no
si sono sempre distinti per il loro
lavoro ma sempre nel bene mai nel male
la globalizzazione è in continuo
movimento fagocita tutto perché vorrebbe
livellare tutto anche le diversità ma
questo è un pericolo le diversità vanno
mantenute perché sono la vera bellezza
ecco che dobbiamo abbandonare l'idea che
la diversità sia qualcosa di negativo e
quindi che la modernità sia l'essere
uguali ma invece abbracciare l'idea che
solo più identità formati da individui
che fondano le loro relazioni su
principi sani di pacifica convivenza può
renderci migliori e può migliorare
questa nostra società
concludo con una poesia dedicata alla
madre intesa in senso più ampio anche
come terra madre
ma the water york new york to the sun
aspetti to use 3 nasci
najeb risulta beh sebbene biel ogni bene
bill pass vip
grazie
[Applauso]